welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is John Merriman charles seymour
professor of history at Yale University
he specializes in modern France urban
and social history and modern European
history since the Renaissance
he has written numerous books including
the red city Lamaze and the French 19th
century margins of city life
explorations on the French urban
frontier and dynamite club how a cafe
bombing ignited to the age of modern
terror today we talk with Professor
Merriman about his new book on the Paris
Commune of 1871 particularly on bloody
week welcome professor
Thank You Marilyn nice to be with you
let's begin with your book please give
us an overview of it well there's been a
lot of books written on the Paris
Commune and what I wanted to do is to
write a book about bloody week that's
kind of a narrative of massacre which is
the name of the book the life and death
of the Paris Commune in which I follow
various percentages through bloody week
and before that too and their lives and
their deaths it's my view that in many
ways bloody week anticipated some of the
demons of the twentieth century when you
could be killed for just merely being
who you were in the case of Armenian
massacres being Armenian or the case of
being a Jew during World War two being
Jewish or being a communist
during over - or being an anti Stalin
communist in the time of the gulag and
and this anticipates lots of these
horror shows so I took a bunch of people
that I found interesting and it's a way
of packing organizing and telling the
story what exactly is the Paris Commune
for those of us well the Paris Commune
was the French got themselves in a
foolish war in 1870 against against
Prussia and their South German allies
and got blown out
in a matter of weeks but Paris found
herself besieged and during that siege
there was a movement on the left
particularly in the more proletarian
parts of Paris for a commune that is an
independent municipal authority that
would continue the war and that would
eventually enact progressive reforms so
after France loses and they lose all of
Alsace which was the second most
industrial region and in France and part
of the Heian albeit but they were vastly
more german-speaking then and
french-speaking there is an insurrection
in Paris because of a conservative
provisional government ordinary
Parisians on Mamata in the eighteenth
Ronde small and in bed and veal in the
twentieth prevent troops from the
provisional government from taking their
cannons the cannons of the National
Guard during the siege and they hold
power for 62 days when Paris was free
there's lots of contradictions lots of
disputes lots of debates but Paris has
besieged again and in the end they get
they get massacred summary at execution
was somewhere minimum of ten twelve
thousand people a maximum of twenty
thousand people get get slaughtered and
you were guilty for being one of the
prosecutors military prosecutors said a
party to the monetha cooper-breaux
that you were guilty if you're a
Parisian that is not wealthy enough to
get out and if you had an affinity for
the Paris Commune and certainly if you
fought for the Paris coming so I
followed these people through scary time
to be in Paris exhilarating time also
but in the ad you know if you go to Pere
Lachaise Cemetery and you realize they
were fighting you know in those
last-ditch struggle in May 26th 27th
28th at the a at the very end in père
Lachaise Cemetery among the tombs and
you see the wall of the federal a where
they were a lot and were shot in their
bodies thrown into into common graves
it's a sort of exhilarating time when
the Paris was free so bloody weak give
us an idea of what that entails well
bloody week was that the the troops
the outside government which was
appropriately enough housed at
Versailles in the shadow of si and ER
the western ramparts of Paris on the
21st of May which was a Sunday and they
fight their way rather rapidly through
inadequate defenses through and around
barricades that were put up by ordinary
men women and children blocking off
smaller streets there was an enormous
one on the Place de la Concorde as well
and the bloody week was the was the end
of the of the Paris Commune
the communi execute some hostages that
they'd taken because if you say a were
the L say troops were were executing
captured communal and some of them
including the Archbishop of Paris were
executed but in the end the coming out
and people in the community for people
and the vel side troops which is a
reticle they've outside troops killed
thousands and thousands of thousands and
covered their bodies with lime and Wow
carted them outside of Paris or threw
them in the river and the gutters of
Paris run red with blood that was a
terrible time so give me an idea of
terms of the numbers of the troops
versus the numbers of the people in the
commune
question tiara who is the head of the
provisional government Adolphe yeah he
built up the army which had been
defeated by the Prussians so we had
about a hundred thirty thousand troops
they'll kill me now in principle that is
the people in the community have 250
national thousand National Guards room
but they really didn't in the end you
know number of twenty thirty maybe forty
thousand National Guardsmen fought and
they tended to fall back on their own
neighborhoods and the the planning of
the defense was was it was very chaotic
so what I do in this book is I take
various people and as I said earlier and
follow their lives so one of them is
this Archbishop dude Joshua Dubois
who's from the old mom in the east of
France and he was not an unsympathetic
character he wasn't what we'd say in
French we goooooo he wasn't a barrel of
laughs but he was had taken on the
Vatican on various things and
and actually cared about ordinary people
and in the end he gets it he's executed
in the 24th of May but I so I follow his
follow him through a little bit about
his earlier life and then in his death
and ironically now I keep getting whited
the old man they give talks they think
I'm you know I'm one of them in fact I
gave a talk there recently in in fy'y Bo
which is where he was born in the earth
mound and I would find myself everybody
else all dressed up except for me as
usual and I found myself giving my talk
about the Paris common between the bust
of the Georgia Bois and his actual
cassock that they somehow had found and
brought and put next to me but he's
somebody that you know in the end I
admire and so he's one of the people
then I took a guy on the Versailles side
who wrote his memoirs about killing and
he's in there too and there's a real
left-wing guy called Raoul regal who was
kind of a subtle kind of a bastard not
because he was left-wing but but he was
kind of a bit crazy he's what used to
call a Blanc East there were proto Lenin
type actually in 83 its way so I follow
him around and he gets his he's killed
on the 24th also and then a woman called
Nathalie LeMat it was a proletarian
married to an alcoholic from Brittany
and she's a pretty good egg so I follow
her along and Louise Michels was sort of
an inevitable character in this who's a
really kind of grim they called her the
red virgin schoolteacher but a very good
socialist politics of the point of view
that call me now so I followed her
around also inevitably Gustave Courbet
the painter the naturalist because he
becomes an important personage in the
Paris Commune and a bunch of other
people so it's a you know it's a hard
it's a hard one to to write about and
because of the way books are these days
I had all sorts of pages oh my god
because publishers are convinced that
people won't buy a book more than 288
pages and they want to get their money
back so the first manuscript was 1150
pages that's how I work and in the end
now it's about when about 500 manuscript
pages so I cut one half of it out
alright so I am curious and in terms of
how you did the research for the book
and how you picked the characters is
there a plethora of people that you
could have picked over
okay so rationally firstly the research
how you did follow them around
that mean weather follow them around is
I mean the Communist got a vassal I'm
under secondary literature but the more
thing but the Communists said you got
their archives and now it's called the
aisle she'll glad I did a lot of a false
where I've you know many many moons in
advance an and so you can follow them on
dossier there and you've got all a whole
host of memoir literature and you've got
dossier on the archbishop in the arch
even ask you now and so basically my
last book was published in 2009 and I
got interested in this because the
father of the last guy there Emil Inari
who's short life I wrote about last time
was in the commune and he saw state
terror up close and so that got me
interested in this topic and of course
we're one of the central themes is is
state terror and the emergence of
strongly national and potentially
terrorist states it's a theme in the
nineteenth century and so because I've
written a lot about Paris I mean a lot
of most of my work is in the provinces a
lot of it but I forgot a lot of books on
Paris I'm interested in the spatial
dynamics or concomitant of of class and
politics and so lots of my book is about
the north eastern part of Paris mo
Martin and robot teen oil which is more
than Northwest but and bevvies and and
and the many more tall and places like
that
people's Paris you got the dichotomy
between more prosperous East and the
poor I'm most prosperous West and the
poor East as you have in London you have
in Vienna and lots of other places but
I've always been interested in why
European and French suburbs in
particular are just the opposite the
mirror image of American suburbs worthy
the unwanted other is in the center city
and in in France is just the opposite
the unwanted other is perched on the
margins of of city life and so that got
me interested in following these people
around in the dynamics of class and with
contention in a very very bloody time
and the nice thing about working on
something like the Paris Commune is the
role of photography I mean you know I've
written a lot about all sorts of things
but I
you can't we have to guess what
Robespierre looked like or we have to
guess what louis xvi looked like or the
14th of the 13th or the 1200 bunch um
but for the first time in 1830
7 you can see Paris in a daguerreotype
and so we have so many rich images of
Paris they found in well the reason I
decided to do this book one day when I
was walking up Elm Street freezing by
Trumbull colleges that I just spent to
an exposition in Paris we live in France
basically but in the south but I'd been
up in Paris where we still have a place
and and they'd found by miracle about 10
years earlier these photos taken by a
you know just this doctor guy who lived
in the West and he photographed the
siege and the commune and so we have
these real images of life and death
and what it was like and when you're
looking down from Omata and the canons
of my mouth I wanted to call it both the
canons of mamata but they didn't like
that title but anyway tons of august
canons of Moammar why not but but but
but you can see I mean the spatial
dynamics of Paris it's all laid out
below
MoMA and so it got me inspired to do
this and you know writing about death
isn't a barrel laughs but these were
some pretty admirable people and it is
interesting to have to be able to read
their perspectives of what was going on
did you actually find photographs of
some we could find I have the right to
have 25 photos in and then you have a
great cover it's basic books in New York
and Yale University Press for the trade
division in Britain in Australia and all
those places but the problem is just
choosing between these just incredible
incredible photos so they don't that
it's rich it's fun I don't like cutting
books I mean I did the history of modern
Europe I turned in 2500 pages and they
said you have to get cut out 800 how are
you gonna do that and I said look at
that learn from that excite them and I
said I'm gonna cut out all the countries
to begin with Abbey
Britain Belarus Belgium in Bulgaria and
they look at me like this man is
completely sangla completely crazy but
that's not how you cut things cut out
but but you just try to tell a story
that's that's analytical but but will
appeal to a general reading audience if
that still exists if there's you know
see Sykes used to okay but now it was a
fun book to write
and I'm already beginning another one
well what about in your in the course of
you working on this book and how long
did you work on it I spent five years in
this book yeah during the course of the
five years did you come across anything
that really said wow that's shocking or
surprising something I didn't expect
well of the degree of the hatred of
ordinary people by social elites and by
rule soldiers who have been taught that
the that the Parisians were the scum of
the earth
and there's the intensity of the hatred
of uppity quote-unquote women who were
building barricades or caring for
wounded soldiers and I guess you know
not surprised and studying a topic in
which it's a civil war the degree of a
hatred but but I guess that was
surprising and also that that having I
guess gone to a Jesuit school I was
prepared not to be terribly sympathetic
to to this Archbishop dude Joshua Dubois
but because he was a Gallic in which
many was for the rights of French
bishops and he did care about ordinary
people and he somebody wouldn't want to
you know hang out with and he didn't
like people wine if you can imagine that
he didn't like to eat very much but he
he ended up being very sympathetic
character and I had to cut lots about
him because I was writing about all
these disputes with the Vatican and and
you know publisher pointed out that
people really care that much about all
that so I was surprised by that too but
it's a lots was not surprising but they
just drama of life and death and the
world's most beautiful city an impost
awesome on Paris too because the
boulevards were built for three reasons
in the 1850s and 60s they were built to
free the flow of capital and the free
the flow of error and have more sewers
and that sort of thing
bring in more light and air into the
city of light but they're also built so
you couldn't build barricades across big
boulevards and so you know that's
another thing I pay attention to in the
final days of this struggle and
I guess one of the challenges is that
that you know it's a book about people
getting killed so their life lining
people up against the wall if they're
wearing military boots or if they have a
an accent from the full-bore in France
and we have different accents and if you
had a real full proletarian ax-head you
were toast
I mean French toast like this to make it
fun but no or if you you know we're
wearing part of a National Guard uniform
or call somebody citizen or even -
instead of vous
you know up against the wall and this
sort of thing so I mean I'm interested
in these kinds of dynamics and in Paris
and the way Paris works so it's you know
it was a it's a lot of fun to to work on
is the last one Emilia already was and
the next book it's about a bunch of
anarchists also sort of mining cloud
before Bonnie and Clyde and I'm already
we're kind of way of that and involves
the suburbs again and and all sorts of
things that I like to write about I fun
doing this stuff okay well the book
sounds fascinating
yes yeah thank you very much for being
here today thank you for having your
work sure for more information about
Professor Merriman and his research
please visit our website at yale.edu
slash macmillan report be sure to join
us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Centre for International and
area studies at Yale